good morning John a Monday added top 5
of conspiracy theories and then you did
top six conjoined twins and now I'm
going back top 5 because I just can't
best you with D top 5 stories that
should have been conspiracy theories but
aren't because they're actually real
conspiracy so my friends let's start
this thing at the beginning with
operation snow white so you know the
Church of Scientology I did not put them
in the conspiracy theories video if
Santos believe that we're all the
reincarnated meat bodies of alien
spirits of the race that came to the
year 75 million years ago and were
destroyed by their leader Zeno then I'm
fine with that but we should take from
that that these are people who are okay
thinking outside of the box so during
the 1970s the Scientologists didn't like
how the US government was getting all up
in their face about how freaking weird
they are so they decided to prove that
they weren't weird to destroy all
government records that portrayed
Scientology in a negative light they did
this amazingly effectively they
infiltrated 136 government agencies they
wiretapped people they hacked computers
operations no ID included no less than
5,000 people making it the largest
infiltration of the US government in
history number two MK ULTRA in the 1960s
it is true that the CIA was conducting
illegal government mind-control
experiments on people the unwitting test
subjects of MKULTRA were given LSD they
were verbally abused physically isolated
put in sensory deprivation chambers and
a conspiracy theorists dream in 1973 the
CIA director ordered all MK ULTRA files
destroyed number three the Tuskegee
Experiment from 1932 to 1972 the
government of America intentionally gave
ineffective treatments to 400 black men
with syphilis it was all part of what
was supposed to be a six month long
study turned into a 40 year long study
in which almost half of the men died of
syphilis or related complications number
four remember remember the fifth
November I kind of feel like I have to
explain that Guy Fawkes wasn't a big
deal in this thing there were a lot of
people working on the plot to blow up
the British Parliament in 1605 and it's
like we call it Guy Fawkes Day but he
was the guy guarding the Gunpowder
obviously not an important dude number
five the business plot this is an
excellent example of why kids shouldn't
go and get a face tattoo or something
because ten years
the line something seems like a really
good idea right now might very well seem
like the worst idea ever
so in 1933 a group of wealthy American
capitalists including george w bush's
grandfather tried to overthrow franklin
delano roosevelt and install a fascist
dictatorship tebah at the time
apparently it didn't seem like a bad
idea all the right-wingers were like
this guy roosevelt is calming up this
place all these government created jobs
being given to people of all
socio-economic statuses races and
religions setting up a public works
program in the poor comma comma comma
Connie at that time in the 30s fascist
dictatorships were kind of all the rage
it was working well in Italy it was
working well in Germany so fascism
seemed like a quick fix these guys let's
get ourselves a nice charismatic general
to run the country and we'll do all the
behind-the-scenes work so they chose
General Smedley Butler to lead their
little military coup but general Butler
it was like what the Frick you guys
didn't even look this up Roosevelt and I
are totally like buds I love that guy
why would I lead a coup against my man
Frankie D so Smedley spilled the whole
plot to Congress he was like these guys
tried to frickin overthrow the
government and they want a beauty in
charge afterwards this is messed up and
somehow the conspiracy continues because
none of the people who try to overthrow
the American government were ever
brought up on charges and there you have
it my top five actual conspiracies John
I'll see you on Monday n screen time
thank you once again to my friend
jessalyn for helping us out with this
episode and for not falling down the
rabbit hole of conspiracy theories
additionally on my let's play channel
youtube.com slash hankgames I've decided
that I'm going to start playing Lego
Harry Potter as soon as I hit 15,000
subscribers so if you want to see me
playing a Harry Potter game then go to
youtube.com slash end games and
subscribe